- versus orangutan so what is that all
about so what I'm going to talk about
today is is kind of something I do on
the side but my day job is my work of
aquatic aware spin-out from the Oxford
mobile robotics group how we work on
self-driving vehicles and mobile
autonomy in general very fun stuff very
lots of cool exciting things going on
and something I'd like to talk about at
some point but maybe for a future
edition on the side I also organize the
London machine learning meetup so I'm
always looking for interesting people
who are doing interesting stuff and cool
stuff from the machine learning front if
you're ever in town or even if you're
not in town and you think you're doing
something interesting machine learning
front we can you know we can get you
travel and things covered let me know
I'm always looking for interesting
people also on the side is I don't live
in a police auntie neighbourhood and not
far from me there's a couple of parks
and there's a lot of littering lying
around and for a long time I've been
bring on this and I've been looking to
build kind of like a a Wally a little
litter or what they can go out and clean
up the litter it's kind of parked at the
moon because of this orangutan stuff so
that's also something I'm almost
thinking how interested in if people are
doing stuff in this area yeah and and on
the same kind of note just a plug also
I'm working with the Witham with it with
some friends to kind of raise awareness
around marine litter so there's a lot of
plastic in the oceans which get washed
up on beaches and so what we're doing is
we're doing a trip around the UK using
collecting drone imagery of the beach of
the of the Strand line of the beaches
and then you can use them again you can
use some machine learning to train in
this case a confident to identify
plastics on the beach and that way you
can map out beaches at quite a large
scale and all the data gets fed back
into a scientific research
it's a project with Imperial College
talent and also something you know we're
looking to broaden out anyway back to
the main topic so who's this Wally what
are you supposed to do with Wally find
them
so where's Wally I'll eat my head if
anybody can see right in the middle
so yeah we all know while you get a
cluttered picture and you know this
somewhere you hiding you go find it so I
got the same problem with the Rankin
tanks with your ranking well actually
there isn't an orangutan with its wicked
test I fail to find a good picture right
now so this is work I'm doing together
well for International Animal Rescue so
there are large animal rescue charity
they've got ovations around the world
where in the UK for example it's a lot
of work around whales dolphins seals
seagulls etc but they also do a lot of
work in a row around orangutan so they
have I think there's two rescue centers
in Indonesia so these are places where
let me backtrack but so orangutan is one
of the five apes and they're extremely
intelligent and Swan animals and
especially these babies they look very
cute so people like to keep them as pets
and this is a whole illegal trade in
these in these animals but of course
while they look very cute is when
they're little and actually they're
they're a nightmare to work with when
they're little anyway so people take
them in as pets but then they older and
any ends a end up in a cage you're tight
over to a post or or generally just
abused or you know they lay with their
natural habitat is the rainforest but
there's a lot of palm oil plantations
and these these plantations are growing
they're chopping down forests these
animals you know don't have a place to
live anymore they end up in the
plantations and so they get found and
essentially they in the end they end up
at a rescue center if they're lucky and
so the point of the rescue center is you
take these animals in there you try to
rehabilitate them you try to patch them
up as best you can
and hopefully if they're not too old or
not too young or not to traumatize you
can release them back into the wild
that's the kind of idea so and there's
there's a I think there's maybe five or
six of these large orangutan rescue
organizations and there's a very there's
a very well-known Dutch one I think boss
Bosnian no Borneo orangutan sanctuary or
something but anyway I've been working
with iar but the problem I'm going to
talk about today is pervasive across all
all organizations right so in particular
there's this post release monitoring
phase so okay you have you
you've taken in the animal let's say you
patched it up and you release it back
into the wild but if you look at how
much money goes into rehabilitating one
of these animals and how much money goes
into running one of these centers you
want to know that when you put the
animal back into the forest does it
survive does it live out for a week two
weeks ten weeks a month you know ideally
the whole point of the whole release
program is you release the animal back
and it lives out a normal natural
healthy lifespan which can be up to
fifty years so but how do you know
that's actually working how do you know
the animal survives so what they
essentially do is they have somebody
follow each animal pretty much 24/7 and
stay within line of sight of the animal
and I keep a very detailed log book and
say ok the animals doing this is heating
it's up in the tree or whatever and they
follow the animal pretty much 24/7 for
the first two to three months and then
let's say the animal is doing alright
then it kind of tapers off to once a
week once every two weeks
etc so well first of all this is
extremely manual intensive you know you
don't really realize that until you're
in up to your knees in the mud and you
soup mosquitoes around your head trying
to you know keep track of some some
April's going through the trees but also
let's say you haven't seen the animal
for a week or two where do you start
looking where where on earth is the
animal now orangutangs make nests or
something I didn't know but every night
they go up and tree in the build a nest
and so they sleep there so you know what
you can do is you go to the last known
nesting site and you can start looking
around there but still it's a needle in
the haystack now of course people say
well okay we've got animal tracking
technology right you've got just a
little little chip or or a collar or
something and you can figure out what
the animal is true but orangutan is a
particularly special case so you try to
put well the typical thing is like a
collar so you put like a call around the
neck now first of all the male's have
these cheek pads and it wouldn't if the
collar would interfere with that and the
way they and the way they seduce the
females etc so now colors not not
allowed and also you know they'd be very
easy to slip off anyway so you think
maybe like a bracelet or or an anklet
but then the rank times they go very
flexible joint so be easy to slide off
and also very clever they're very strong
so that anything you attach through
the sub biting chewing and pulling or
they get somebody else to bite into a
pullout it so nothing is impossible but
it's very tricky and also what you don't
want to do is you want to do this like
say you manage to get on a color but
then the battery runs out what you don't
want to do is you want to catch the
animal again to replace the battery or
you know the animal is going to gain
weight it's going to lose weight so how
you have something with the depth again
not obvious so what the kind of solution
is people use now are implants so a
little implant about the size in the UK
I would say about size of a one-pound
coin but doesn't really mean anything
here but let's say size of a two year
old piece but about a centimeter thick
goes in the back of the neck because
they've got this fatty patch there and
this implant came out of a collaboration
with an Austrian University and this
sends out a pulse of pinging every two
seconds at a specific frequency
there's no modulation there's no data or
anything is just literally an on-off
pulse and every animal has a different
frequency and that's how you can tell
between them it's okay you have a pot so
you have this ping now if you're in the
jungle you've got a big antenna and then
you put on some headphones and then you
can wave the antenna around trying to
listen where the ping comes from and
that will give you around 200 meters
range so that's better than
line-of-sight but 200 meters in the
dense jungle is not much so even you
know if you haven't seen the animal
again for two weeks you have to go
essentially go whacking your way through
the bush pretty much random search until
you hopefully end up in this 200 meter
bubble around the animal so a lot of a
lot of time is wasted here so yeah as
you can see you know this is what you're
working your way through for of course
the idea is can we do this from the air
and so this is a problem that ended up
on my desk I think almost almost two
years ago now so the idea is can we have
a drone that can take off fly above the
forest it has a suitable payload that
can listen for these pings and then
because the drone knows where it is as
GPS you're up in the air you've got
plenty of satellites so then the drone
knows where it is it listens so you can
pick up the ping and then it will come
back to land and you can get kind of a
heat map that tells you okay the animal
is there that's the idea make sense
right so that was a
the problem that arrived on my desk and
so can we do this now first of all just
a reality check because people often get
carried away and there's one thing
technology you know we're all
technologists here and technologists
like to masturbate with technology I'm a
I'm sorry but no people get carried away
I wanted to talk about this and at some
some some drone event and the lady promo
English talk hehehe wrote like an
article you know an interview and it was
like drones going to save orangutan from
extension kind of thing but it's
ridiculous of course or not so all we're
doing here with the drone is we're
turning a needle into a haystack needle
in a haystack problem into a needle in a
bail problem you know we still got a fly
you know up and down try to search this
thing but we can do it a lot more
efficiently but it's not going to solve
the fundamental problem the fundamental
problem is people are chopping down the
rainforests in these animals ending up
in sanctuaries John's not going to help
that okay you can use them for mapping
and mapping the habitat destruction but
these things are complex or social
political even religious issues that tie
into this then or can I save orangutans
from extinction unfortunately but it is
for the specific case it makes sense to
use in what we really want to do is we
want to have better implants or better
tracking technology so ideally we can we
can track them remotely much more easily
but that doesn't really exist yet and
I'm always looking for people with ideas
here so the core problem is really
habitat destruction and it's pretty
complex and it is pretty depressing but
that's just kind of a reality check but
that's not to say they have their place
right anyway so the idea was let's start
very simple so pre-programmed flight
path and we just map signal strength and
or in space so idea being you different
you come up with your flight path and
you just do you know lawn mower type
pattern up down up down and out you
cover an area and then you land then you
can generate this kind of heat mapping
say okay well there's three and three or
four animals there and that's where
awfully where they are we don't need to
know the position in you know up to 10
centimeters accurate it's already good
enough we've you know up to 50 meters
you know even 100 meters radius so we
don't have to be very precise they just
want to know you know where is the
animal roughly has it been moving we can
do this by multiple flights and they'll
always want to go check up on an annual
on an animal manually anyway because
they would just always want kind of a
visual check to see how the animal is so
you know pros of this is is simple it's
you can easily accommodate multiple
animals and you know it's fairly
quote-unquote easy to put this together
the disadvantage is it's not very
efficient you can imagine if anybody
anybody here working with radio knows a
lot about RF or like I can say what I
want then I guess but so you could
imagine you know somebody who knows a
bit about radio they go well hang on why
are we doing this up and down we can
just we should take off we use two
antennas we have some kind of
directional system we take off and we
rotate 360 degrees we locate where the
signal is the strongest and we go
straight at it you can kind of do kind
of like a gradient descent you know in
terms to get your optimum and sure you
can come up with something like that but
you still have to build it and operate
it in the jungle etc and there's a lot
more failure modes and things it complex
and if there's anything I learned from
this is complexity is not good
so we know let's start simple so what I
started with was you know a fair a
fairly standard you know nothing
particularly fancy off the shelf
dev dev drone should we say there's lots
of mounting points and easy easy to
access something using a pixel or a
pilot anybody fly fly any drones here
any none since its kind of no it's you
know these things are very fun to play
with they're very easy to get into it's
not very expensive at all and you know
like a pixhawk so that's the little
thing that's the autopilot that's an
open-source autopilot you all the code
is there it's got nice Python api's you
can you know you can really toy with us
if you're a program there's a lot of
very fun stuff you can do with not
little money we just needed a bit of
creativity definitely worth checking out
so anyway so we have our pixel click
that controls the drone so that will you
know it makes it has gyros and
accelerometers etc so make sure drone
stable and it can do Waypoint following
if you plug in the GPS etc exit so
that's the drone then we need some kind
of payload so we've got these these
implants here at the bottom so those are
the things are generating the ping that
we need an antenna to actually receive
the analog signal
and then we need a radio that turns the
analog signal into a digital set of
samples and those those digital samples
then plug into a little single board
computer so think this is a raspberry in
this case it's not a Raspberry Pi but
you know same kind of thing which is
more powerful and then on top of that we
just run Python and then we have a web
front-end sitting on top of that so
that's kind of every how everything
plugs together and again you know people
who know a lot about signal processing
and electronics you could debate whether
this is a good way of doing this but
that's I'm happy to have that debate but
that's a separate story so and by the
way the radio at the top is just in this
case just a USB dongle is what we
typically call a software-defined radio
so again these are fun things if you
want to you know receive a radio station
on your laptop let's say you can buy one
who's almost plug it in and then you
have essentially a digital stream of
samples that you can tune to any
frequency and then you can demodulate
your FM radio or transmit stuff for you
there's all kinds of things you can do
anyway so as for programming stack so on
the drone this drone kit tight and
lovely Python API that used to interface
with the drone you can tell it take off
land go to this GPS position slide the
cells to turn around whatever very nice
and for this particular case for this
SDR so this radio this end there's a
Python library which you can use then
all the signal processing is just your
standard scientific Python stack multi
processing numpy etc and then on the
front end I just did a little web
front-end with them using leaflet react
etc they just talked to the backend
nothing particularly nothing to taking
flashy so the detection logic itself so
what you get in is from this radio is
essentially a numpy array of complex
numbers which represent your samples
over time and then there's there's
different now there's many different
ways you can approach this and I've kind
of changed it kind of change it in the
current iteration but essentially you're
collecting samples and then you what I
was doing is you look in the frequency
domain so Fourier transforms does that
mean anything to anybody
Fourier transform okay so good so some
nodding there so essentially you do a
Fourier transform and you can look in
you look at the spectrum and you can
figure out was there a burst of energy
at
particular frequency that corresponds to
the implant but that's useful but I
guess since this is essentially
time-domain phenomenom you have this
pulse in time you should also look at
this in the time domain so then you can
do things like cross correlations does
that mean anything to people you know
time series of people in the financial
world will know this so you know you can
do those time things on the signal as
well all of this so this is what's
happening essentially we we listen for
two seconds and then we we do some
Fourier transforms we do some time
domain analysis and then we have some
heuristics to kind of figure out okay
did I hear a pulse or didn't I
you're going to have false positives
false negatives it's not a hard science
but that's a separate problem all of
this happens completely offline on board
on the drone there's no communication
with the base station so and there's a
kind of a web app you can use to
interfaces so the way this works is you
have the drone you draw out your your
mission so which air you interested in
that will generate a flight plan and
then you hit hit starts and this will
start the loop going and then drone will
take off it'll start flying and in the
air it will be collecting samples doing
the processing and recording the results
and the drone comes back it has its own
Wi-Fi hotspot again you just use your
tablet your phone to connect to the
drone and then you can just visualize
the results on a map so that's the way
the workflow works so yeah these are
some kind of pictures that you get so in
this case we collect a bunch of samples
and this is essentially a spectrum so
this is the output of your your DFT and
we do some filtering and you some cut
off some things and this kind of
filtered signal and this is something in
the time domain but ignore the bottom
one so you know you get a fairly noisy
spectrum and doesn't seem to be any
anything obvious going on so that's
where there's no pulse but this is an
example whether there is a pulse so you
can see a definite you know verse of
energy here in a certain part of the
spectrum which if you filter out you see
there's a definite peak there which
stands out so this is the case where yes
we've detected a pulse there was a pulse
there so in this case you can very
confidently say okay I know this is
definitely a real signal and you know at
that point in time what your GPS
location was so that gives you an
approximation for the true location of
the animal
make sense so you know we the very first
thing we did was proof of principle so
an off-the-shelf drone this is an indie
GI inspire a lovely lovely drone for
doing aerial filming I would just
strapped a big yagi antenna this is the
antenna they use in the bush and we put
an implant somewhere how we just kind of
hovered it and can we detect something
the big worry was you could the drone
you've always motor spinning you got in
this case your ultrasound going off so
there's a lot of going on is that going
to create electrical interference or
radio interference that's going to
interfere with the detection of the this
very weak signal and so this is you know
it flew like a dog but it kind of worked
and then you look at the results and we
thought wow this is very very basic
little heat map saying okay we could get
some detections it wasn't great but it
kind of proved the principle okay yeah I
think we can do something here and then
you know this is this was pretty much
six to eight months of my life
I did live on the south coast of the UK
not far from a large nature sanctuary
should we say or wildlife park so I
spent a lot of my time with my knees in
the mud in the cold with the drone and I
would take the implants I would go put
it somewhere the known location and I
you know fiddled with the software fly
you know fly fly grid come back look at
the results and then you know and I
wouldn't detect something I were the way
wrong or things would break and you know
iterate so a lot a lot of time was spent
there and I think pretty much everything
everything go wrong so just give idea of
the workflow so I put the drone put the
transmitter in alone known location and
then I would just flick a switch and the
drone takes off by itself goes to the
specified altitude and will start flying
so in the in the beginning you start
very easy ten meters so nice and low
quite nice and slow I you just fly up
and down up and down up and down and
then you know all the way up to 120
meters this is from a camera on the
drone so this is the legal limit you're
allowed to fly in the UK and this was
also the highest I managed to get some
detection so I was pretty happy with
this actually 120 meters pretty high in
and that's more than good enough for
what I need in Borneo however of course
this is you know this is South UK's I'm
very representative of Borneo first of
all there's no jungle but okay you know
start simple and work your way work self
off okay and then come back down to land
and I think yeah so these are the kind
of plots I was getting so this is just
matplotlib running over some the data
that was generated and I can look at
ground speed and altitude
so here altitude I was going 30 meters
roughly and then there's various
heuristics I used to kind of figure out
is there a pulse or not and the star is
the true location of the of the implant
because I know what that is because I
put it down so I know the true location
and then the the heat map is kind of my
heuristics and so what you want is my
like a big red blob around the star
because that's the true location you
know that kind of worked out again the
accuracy well doesn't have any units on
here but you're talking about you know I
think in the order of 20 30 meters or so
which is which is fine and then the the
same thing also yeah so those 25 meters
and then 40 meters and then you know all
the way up to 80 meters and still and
this is 120 meters so even here there's
only one true detection but you know
still within a twenty thirty rain meter
range of the actual implant so that was
pretty good
so that's I was happy with that so then
packed up everything and then oh no off
to off to Borneo so this was a last last
spring so they have their main site in
in West Kalimantan that's where they
have the sanctuary and there's the the
animals come in first and so as soon as
I arrived there started doing the exact
same thing so put the put the implant
somewhere you know in the forest and
then start flying now in this case we
had somebody else there who had a
filming drone and so this was this is
quite cool and we had one drone flying
and filming the other drone doing its
thing it was a bit hard to kind of
follow the drone
but yeah it was a great fun getting this
to work but it's impressive you look at
the stability of the camera you know
this is on a platform it's a really
impressive piece of kid so here you know
I think about 50 meters or so and here
there was jungle still not the same
pristine jungle as we'd see in the final
release site but much more
representative and this is where the
nightmare began because everything which
is break I'd seen pretty much everything
break before but now suddenly 40 degrees
and my voltage regulator soon cooked
itself the computer was one degree away
from cooking itself it would it would
shut down at a hundred degrees it was
constantly like 98 97 so then I you try
to get the Sun away and then the battery
is well it was just an absolute
nightmare
and then of course with the jungle the
sensitivity was a lot lower so I had to
fly lower and I to fly slower which
means endurance was lesser oh it was it
was a lot of frantic fiddling out there
in and trying to fix it with code and
there's no network or there's a you know
if you're very lucky or this is weird 3G
signals
anyway but so a lot of time was spent
but okay progress was was kind of made
where is it
in the end it's the same thing come down
to land again is it actually oh yeah
there it is so this is the Crete which
we say that the actual center so that's
where they have large cages where they
keep the animals and things and there's
also a section of the forest that
they've kind of cordoned off which is
their pre-release site so these are
animals I think a good enough to be
released but just to make sure you put
them in a pre-release site just to kind
of see how they behave it's a fairly
small area but you and you can track
them very closely you could just kind of
see how they do and if you feel
confident then you move on to the actual
release site so this is where I started
flying over this pre-release site and
fortunately the the implants I was using
in the UK were actually a bit weaker
than the ones they actually used over in
Borneo so I was actually getting a
stronger signal there than before so
that was like that compensated them for
the other loss in altitude and
sensitivity so now I started flying and
got some very good detection
that was good but the real the real
progress came when I did the first
proper test the ie flying completely
blind so all I knew there was an animal
somewhere there I didn't know where and
then I would fly you know fly the path
and come back and then I would have to
say I think the animal is there and then
they would radio the guard who is
actually with the animals say where are
you and the two locations had to match
up and in this case the results were
really nice you got you got this very
nice little hot spot there and so that's
where I thought the animal was and
that's where it turned out to be and
it's actually until then the charity was
really quite skeptical about the whole
thing you know there's some weird guy in
the UK using drones and how they're
going to solve their orangutan tracking
problem and you find you know rightfully
so conservation people are usually often
quite cynical for various reasons and
quite skeptical of technology as well
because they've seen a lot of promises
and they're conservative oh yeah person
I don't the pun was intended but okay
but so that was kind of the first the
first case where okay hang on this this
could actually work this could actually
be useful so that was nice
oh yeah so this is kind of a screenshot
of kind of the interface is not great I
know UI person but it is functional so
the idea is you you put in yeah there's
some radio parameters and then you you
can start you can add a number of
animals that you detecting you start
flying and these are the roll results
and you can render the results on the
map okay so okay that kind of work to
know we went off to the the real release
site and this was a very long journey
through mud and all the rest of it got
there in the end and then after a few
hours of trekking through the jungle
this is kind of their base camp and we
do the same thing and and the first
thing I had when I arrived there was
like oh hang on where am I going to take
off where I'm going to land from because
there's as you can see it's not many
places and this was the best spot the
found just literally where the base camp
was and there's about five by you know
five by five meters or so which if
you're standing right at the bottom you
think okay I need to take off here it's
you know it's slightly nerve-racking
so in this case we had again we trying
to verify this thing works now in an
actual environment so we we knew there
was an animal about two kilometers away
with and there was a there was a
somebody following her so like okay
let's let's go up to 100 meters let's
fly - out two kilometers let's do a
search and then let's come back this are
just making a flight plan for this
turned out to be a pain because I need
to know relative altitudes of the Train
around me because I needed to set the
height we have these fancy GPS receivers
but the bottom of Academy there's no GPS
reception and they all disagreed and the
margins you know the errors were way off
so kind of the end you just kind of had
to guess and pick our number and
hopefully it's not too high or too low
and and then also I was flying
completely blind
I had three eye three systems in place
for maintaining a communication link for
the drone all three of them failed for
different reasons so I had nothing all I
could do is take off till the drone to
go I see the drone disappear and just
kind of cross your fingers and hope it
comes back literally so and then you
know you know the flight time is around
you know 20 minutes tops and so in this
case I was very happy when you're
waiting there like 15 minutes and then
suddenly you see the thing come come
back so that was great so now is 100
meters but then I had to take over
manually to kind of land it again and so
this was pretty pretty nerve-wracking as
well and then bring it down so while I
had no comms link with the with the
drone the only thing what I did have is
just there is a very basic radio signal
to connect your transmitter with the
drone and all you know is it's connected
or not and that gives you a range of
about a kilometer that's so all you know
is okay it's roughly within a kilometer
range
and the plastic thing you can see
actually that's the antenna that's stuck
to the bottom yeah so that was those so
that was a really big sigh of relief the
thing landed again so okay then very
quickly you know hook up the laptop and
start looking and downloading
downloading the the data and
unfortunately we had no detection
nothing oh bugger
but then again turned out the animal had
moved somewhat so okay maybe we got the
area wrong we would be too high anyway
and we we got a bit optimistic and they
said okay let's lower the altitude
someone and and so we get maybe a better
signal so so we did that and so change
the flight plan change the area a bit
lower the altitude and send the whole
thing off again and then it started
flying about 15 minutes the transmitter
reconnects and say okay roughly when the
in kilometer range and then then
somebody went silent there's nothing in
your life like 15 20 minutes and you can
looking around and then the no drone and
then that's a post more well you know is
25 minutes he like no this thing is not
coming back so it's like okay so what
what happened so then studying detailed
maps and you know overlaying the flight
plan trying to send what it might have
done etc and then turns out what we
should what we should have done is just
lower the altitude at the place where we
are searching but not change the
altitude where we dash out and dash back
again we lower the altitude everywhere
so on these two kilometer leg where we
going out with instead of 100 meters we
were an hour - I don't know 70 meters or
so it turned out that roughly a
kilometer away this is big hill with
some high trees and probably on the way
back it clipped the tree and then it got
stuck in the tree somewhere we tried to
find it but it's absolutely hopeless so
okay I kind of was half expecting that
was going to happen so you know but it
was a bit of a shame but we did kind of
prove the concept so that was good and
then few more literally two months ago I
get an email saying Dirk we found the
drone ad yeah so this is a picture they
sent me so the locals they go out into
the forest and a lot and I guess they
they saw something somewhere and then
these are the bits and pieces they
together unfortunately they didn't find
the camera I would have loved to see
what was on the camera there but anyway
so I still have some bits and pieces so
anyway so overall I was very happy it
kind of proved the concept etc and so
but what I needed
I need the more sensitivity and better
drone and also some terrain-following
etc so this is kind of what I mean
working on the moment so well okay
future lessons the real world is hard it
is hard things break everything breaks
it's it's um you know if you don't test
it it's not going to work pretty much
guaranteed simplicity and robustness
over everything so SFA's to better radio
better detection electronics new
upgraded drone etc and in parallel
looking at better implants so as to
where I'm now I've been doing a lot of
work
again all Python comparing different
radio settings and different
sensitivities and trying to optimize the
configuration i've also switched to
using new radio as I guess if nobody's
done in radio anybody know about new
radio oh yeah couple people have to say
it's really good it's amazing it takes a
bit of while to wrap your head around
how it works in the philosophy itself
but if you want to do something with
radio you want to process a radio stream
it has literally this kind of flow chart
based approach and you drag-and-drop
blocks and you connect them and it
generates Python code or generate C++
code it's really nice so I've kind of
reimplemented all my detection stuff in
blue radio and that seems to be working
a lot better
there's or some performance issues I
need to iron out but so far that's
looking good and I think I kind of done
the best I can do now based on that
approach but definitely worth checking
out so also I you know built another
drone so this is what I've been testing
with until very recently so again I now
have a proper payload box whereas before
everything was kind of strapped to the
drone with Velcro and cable ties oh no
sorry
and you know some amplification that's
going on some other things just to clean
up the single and get me get me a
cleaner signal so I've been testing that
a lot but then of course things break
and things crash and I and I got a bit
optimist
flying and there was a lot of wind and
it was kind of the last it would have
been going fine but just I needed to one
one more flight and I was up about 50 60
meters and I said yes and you could see
some rain coming in and the rain would
sweep through and then just you know
within five or six seconds the drones
start wobbling and then it turned upside
down and hit the ground so luckily it's
not so bad so I can fix it
so this was literally a few weeks ago
luckily I have another drone this so
this is a team black sheep system it's
actually it's a very nice piece of kit
it's a long endurance drone and so
that's what I'm strapping the the
payload to now and this is going to be
my last development platform so if this
kind of works out then I'll be looking
to build the final system which either
will be a multi rotor but ideally I'd
like a hybrid fixed-wing to give me more
endurance but what I have to see so the
aim is to take this back to Borneo end
of May early early June probably and
that's the plan anyway so just a fully
wrap up program done over time too much
but I just closed with with this so
while I was down there you meet a lot of
people who work in conservation and this
is just one quote one of them said that
stuck with me so Leo Biddle he runs one
of the other sanctuaries in in Sumatra
they do a lot more than orangutan so
much larger but you know they do a lot
of work but and he's a great guy but
because we were talking about
conservation except for why they do what
they do etc and his quote was
conservation is creating hope where
there is none and it was really quite
depressing he said look you know you can
it's very depressing if you look at how
FAR's is disappearing out how all these
cultural political issues etc and you
know you just try to do what you do and
you try to create the hope there is but
it's it's kind of almost a looks like a
battle you can't win but you know you
need to you need to keep fighting
so that was very humbling and makes you
think quite a bit and see how how
everybody can kind of pitch in but
anyway I'll close on that and just to
say you know this is kind of an open
project people interesting to help out I
know Vince adores being awesome and
sending me some stuff which I will get
to but you know any
from web development of particularly
people on the RF electronic side is
probably not the audience here but ya
know any questions or thoughts or
whatever let me know kiss
[Applause]